well let me uh let me zoom out for a
second
uh let's get into your paper on the
measure of intelligence
that uh did you put on 2018 yes
okay yeah november november
yeah remember 2018 that was a different
time
yeah i remember i still remember
[Laughter]
it feels like a different and different
different world
you could travel or you could you know
actually go outside and
see friends yeah
let me ask the most absurd question i
think uh
there's some non-zero probability
there'll be a textbook one day like 200
years from now
on artificial intelligence or it'll be
called like
just intelligence because humans will
already be gone it'll be your picture
with a quote you know one of the early
biological systems would consider the
nature of intelligence
and they'll be like a definition of how
they thought about intelligence
which is one of the things you do in
your paper on measure intelligence is
to ask like well
what is intelligence and and uh how to
test for intelligence and so on
so is there a spiffy quote
about what is intelligence
what is the definition of intelligence
according to a friend so i surely
so do you think the the superintendent
ais of the future will
want to remember us the way we remember
humans from the past
and do you think they will be you know
they won't be ashamed of having a
biology biological origin
no i i think it would be a niche topic
it won't be that interesting but it'll
be
it'll be like the people that study in
certain contexts
like historical civilization and longer
exist
the aztecs and so on that that's how
it'll be seen
and it'll be study in the also the
context
on social media there'll be hashtags
about
the atrocity committed to human beings
um
when when the when the robots finally
got rid of them
like it was a mistake it'll be seen as a
as a giant mistake but ultimately
in the name of progress and it created a
better world because humans were
over consuming the resources and all
they were not very rational or
destructive
in the end in terms of productivity and
putting more love in the world and so
within that context there'll be a
chapter about these biological systems
seems to have a very detailed vision
of that feature you should write a
sci-fi novel about it i said i'm i'm
working i'm
working on a sci-fi novel currently yes
yeah self-published yeah the definition
of intelligence so
intelligence is the efficiency
with which you acquire new skills
tasks that you did not previously know
about that you did not
prepare for right so it is not
intelligence is not
skill itself it's not what you know it's
not what you can do
it's how well and how efficiently you
can learn
new things new things yes the idea of
newness there
seems to be fundamentally important
yes so you would see intelligence on
display for instance
uh whenever you see a human being or you
know an ai creature adapt
to a new environment that it has not
seen before that its creators did not
anticipate
when you see adaptation when you see
improvisation when you see
generalization that's intelligence in
reverse
if you have a system that when you put
it in a slightly new environment it
cannot
adapt it cannot improvise it cannot
deviate from what's
it's hard-coded to do or um what
and what it has been trained to do
that is a system that is not intelligent
so there's actually a quote from
einstein that captures this idea which
is
the measure of intelligence is the
ability to change
i like that quote i think it captures at
least part of this idea you know there
might be something interesting about the
difference between
your definition and einsteins i mean
he's just being
einstein and clever
but acquisition of
new ability to deal with new things
versus ability to just change
what's the difference between those two
things so just
changing itself do you think there's
something to that
just being able to change yes being able
to adapt so not
not change but certainly uh
changes direction being able to adapt
yourself
to your environment whatever the
environment is
that's a big part of intelligence yes
and intelligence is most precisely you
know
how efficiently you're able to adapt how
efficiently you're able to
basically master your environment how
efficiently
you can acquire new skills and i think
there's a there's a big distinction to
be drawn
between intelligence which is a process
and the output of that process which is
skill
so for instance if you have a very smart
human programmer
that considers the game of chess and
that writes down
a static program that can play chess
then
the intelligence is the process of
developing that program
but the program itself is just
encoding um the output artifact
of that process the program itself is
not intelligent and the way you tell
it's not intelligent
is that if you put it in a different
context you ask it to play go or
something
it's not going to be able to perform
well without human involvement because
the source of intelligence
the entity that is capable of that
process is the human programmer
so we should be able to tell the
difference between
the process and its output we should not
confuse
uh the output and the process it's the
same as you know
do not confuse uh a road building
company
and one specific road because one
specific road takes you from point a to
point b
but a road building company can take you
from you can
make a path from anywhere to anywhere
else yeah that's beautifully put but
it's also
to play devil's advocate a little bit
you know it's possible that there's
something
more fundamental than us humans so
you kind of said the programmer creates
uh the difference between the the choir
of the skill and the skill itself
there could be something like you could
argue the universe
is more intelligent like the the deep
the base intelligence of um that we
should be
trying to measure is something that
created humans
we should be measuring god or
the source of the universe as opposed to
like there's there could be a deeper
intelligence sure there's always deeper
neurologists you can argue that but that
does not take
anything away from the fact that humans
are intelligence and you can't tell that
because they are capable of adaptation
and and generality
um and you see that in particular in the
fact that
[Music]
humans are capable of handling
situations
and tasks that are quite different from
anything that any of our evolutionary
ancestors
has ever encountered so we are capable
of generalizing
very much out of distribution if you
consider our evolutionary history as
being
in in a way of training data course
evolutionary biologists would argue that
we're not going too far out of the
distribution we're like
mapping the skills we've learned
previously
desperately trying to like jam them into
like
these new situations i mean there's
definitely a little bit
a little bit of that but it's pretty
clear to me that you're able to
uh you know most of the things we do
any given day in our modern civilization
are things that
are very very different from what you
know our ancestors a million years ago
would have been doing in
in a given day and your environment is
very different so
i agree that um everything we do
we do it with cognitive building blocks
that we acquire
over the course of revolution right and
that anchors
our cognition to a certain context which
is the human
condition very much uh but still
our mind is capable of a pretty
remarkable degree of generality
far beyond anything we can create in
artificial systems today
like the degree in which the mind can
generalize
from its evolutionary history
can generalize away from its
evolutionary history is much greater
than the
degree to which a deep learning system
today can generalize away from its
training data
and like the key point you're making
which i think is quite beautiful is like
we shouldn't
measure if we talk about measurement we
shouldn't measure the skill
we should measure like the creation of
the new skill the ability to create that
new skill
yes but there it's tempting like
it's weird because the skill is a little
bit of a small window
into the into the system so whenever you
have a lot of skills
it's tempting to measure the skills yes
i mean the skill is the
uh only thing you can objectively uh
measure
but yeah so the the thing to keep in
mind is that
when you see skill in the human
it gives you a strong signal that that
human is intelligent
because you know they weren't born with
that skill typically
like you say this you see a very strong
chess player maybe you're a very strong
chess player yourself
i think you're and you're you're saying
that because i'm russian and now now
you're
you're prejudiced you assume oh yeah
i'm biased yeah well you're dead by
so if you see a very strong chess player
you know they weren't born
uh knowing how to play chess so they had
to acquire that skill
with their limited resources with their
limited lifetime
and you know they did that because they
are generally intelligent
and so they may as well have acquired
any other skill you know they have this
potential
and on the other hand if you see
a computer playing a chess you cannot
make the same assumptions
because you cannot you know just assume
the computer is generally intelligent
the computer may be
born knowing how to play chess
in the sense that it may have been
programmed by a human that
has understood chess for the computer
and and that has just encoded
um the output of that understanding in
aesthetic program and that program
uh is not intelligent so let's zoom out
just for a second and
say like what is the goal of the
on the measure of intelligence paper
like what do you hope to achieve with it
so the goal of the paper is to clear up
some
long-standing misunderstandings about
the way
we've been conceptualizing intelligence
in the ai community
and in the way we've been evaluating
progress in ai um
there's been a lot of progress recently
in machine learning and people are you
know extrapolating from that progress
that we're about
to solve general intelligence
and if you want to be able to evaluate
these statements
you need to precisely define what you're
talking about when you're talking about
general intelligence and you need
a formal way a reliable way to measure
how much intelligence how much general
intelligence a system processes
and ideally this measure of intelligence
should be
actionable so it should not just
describe
uh what intelligence is it should not
just be a binary indicator that tells
you
the system is intelligent or it isn't
um it should be actionable it should
explanatory
power right so you could use it as a
feedback signal it would show you
the way towards building more
intelligent systems
you